la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect au respect bien sûr
des uns et des autres et au respect du
temps de parole je vais donner
immédiatement la parole au président
Guillaume Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre lors de votre
déclaration de politique générale vous
avez décidé de hurler avec les loups en
évoquant lors de je je recommence si
c'est possible monsieur le Premier
ministre lors de votre déclaration de
politique générale vous avez décidé de
hurler avec les loups en évoquant une
écologie de la brutalité
nouvelle stratégie de diversion
estampillé minse vous faites ainsi vôre
le propos de ceux qui à droite et à
l'extrême droite n'ont jamais eu la
moindre ambition écologique votre unique
objectif qui n'a rien de populaire est
de préserver coûte que coûte la capacité
des plus aisés à polluer et émettre
trois fois plus de CO2 que les plus
modestes pourtant le président en
campagne avait déclaré ce quinquena sera
écologique ou ne sera pas alors Monsieur
le Premier Ministre quand démarrera le
quinena pour vous répondre
la parole est au Premier ministre
monsieur le Premier
ministre merci Monsieur le merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le Président Gontard nous avons
dans cet hémicycle comme dans le pays
des débats qui sont toujours légitimes
pouvons avoir des visions qui sont
opposées des propositions qui sont
différentes et je crois que c'est ça en
démocratie de pouvoir les confronter
mais il y a certaines je l'avoue que je
ne comprends pas
totalement d'abord je ne comprends pas
totalement ou pas du tout même pourquoi
est-ce qu'il vous est aussi impossible
de mettre en avant les progrès que nous
obtenons s'agissant de la défense de la
planète et de
l'environnement je rappelle qu'avant
2017 les émissions de CO2 diminuaient à
un rythme moyenne moyen annuel de 1 %
que dans le premier quinena ça a été 2 %
par an et que l'année dernière sur les 9
premiers mois de l'année seulement c'est
5 % d'émissions de CO2 en moins je ne
comprends pas que vous ne puissiez pas
vous en réjouir vous qui êtes un groupe
écologiste parce que ce succès ça n'est
pas celui du seul gouvernement ni de la
seule majorité c'est celui des
industriels qui ont changé leur mode de
production c'est celui de nos
agriculteurs qui ont aussi fait des
efforts en matière de conversion c'est
celui de toute une société qui se
mobilise pour défendre la planète
ce que je ne comprends pas davantage
c'est d'avoir entendu et vu des élus
écologistes aller sur les barrage aller
au côté des agriculteurs ces dernières
semaines pendant leur mouvement pour
dire qu'ils épousaient leur
revendications et qu'ils étaient à leur
côté et les soutenait et depuis que nous
avons trouvé une solution et donné des
perspectives aux agriculteurs en lien
avec eux il y a quelques jour maintenant
critiquer méthodiquement toutes les
solutions qui ont été trouvées avec nos
agricultrices et et nos agriculteurs je
ne le comprends
pas je ne le comprends
pas alors vous critiquez la position qui
est la mienne celle de mon gouvernement
dans ma déclaration de politique
générale je vous confirme monsieur le
Président Gontard que pour nous
l'écologie ça ne peut pas être un
facteur d'opposition
entre les ruraux et les urbains entre la
droite et la gauche et je le dis
j'appartiens à un gouvernement de
dépassement politique avec des personnes
d'horizon politique différent non mais
je le dis très sincèrement je le dis
très sincèrement la planète la planète
est trop importante la planète est trop
importante pour qu'elle soit l'otage de
positionnement politicien comme vous
venez de le faire moi je le dis je
reconnais le travail qui a été fait y
compris par des majorités de droite par
le passé par Jean-Louis borlot par
natthalie cossuscoiset par des ministres
de l'écologie qui se sont engagés queles
que soient les majorités pour avancer et
permettre à notre pays d'avancer alors
je vous confirme que nous ne nous
livrerons pas à l'opposition entre les
ruraux et les urbains entre les Français
qui ont besoin de leur voiture pour
aller travailler ou tout simplement pour
vivre et les Français qui peuvent s'en
passer entre les agriculteurs et la
planète je n'accepterai jamais les
discours qui visent en permanence à
culpabiliser à punir à sanctionner à
brutaliser l'écologie à laquelle je
crois et vous devez le respecter aussi
c'est une écologie qui investit qui
accompagne qui soutient parce que je
pense qu'on va plus loin pour la planète
plus loin pour notre pays en suivant
cette ligne là qu'en cherchant à
adresser les uns contre les autres comme
vous le
faites monsieur monsieur Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Président Monsieur le
Premier monsieur le Premier ministre le
clivage c'est vous c'est c'est ce que je
vous reproche c'est la BR brutalité de
votre immobilisme Jean-René 50 ans est
décédé dans les Côtes d'Armor après
avoir respiré le sulfure d'hydrogène
émis par les algue Verde lors d'un
jogging brutal Tho 16 ans a subi 54
interventions sous anesthésie général
pour reconstruire ses systèmes digestifs
et respiratoires une bataille de chaque
instant pour respirer manger et parler
le glyphosate en est le responsable
avéré brutal Marie apicultrice bio dans
le triève voit ses abeilles disparaître
chaque année après année avec un taux de
mortalité de 35 % une écatombe les
pesticides en sont la première cause
brutale Marius agriculteur dans l'enjus
ne peut plus consommer l'autre se
rombiné pollué par les solevants brutal
Noémie en Guadeloupe veut un enfant
c'est cependant que le clord desconne 30
ans après son interdiction aura un
impact négatif sur le cerveau de son
bébé brutal Lucas 6 mois famille modeste
habite au bord du périphérique a été
hospitalisé en urgence pour une
bioncotilite sévère d à la pollution
brutale cette brutalité ces punitions
aveugles cette décroissance du vivant
cette injustice érigée en dogme entre
ceux qui peuvent tout et ceux qui
subissent c'est votre bilan c'est la
brutalité et la brutalité c'est votre
renoncement
don la parole notre collègue califé
califé pour le groupe les républicains
vous avez la parole mon chers
cèg merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
consacré une bonne partie de votre
discours de politique générale à la
santé permettez-moi d' votre attention
aujourd'hui sur la dégradation des
finances de des 32 CHRU et plus
spécialement les établissement public de
santé cette situation brutale vient de
mettre en péril l'embellli constaté
aujourd'hui sur le plan de
l'attractivité mais aussi de la
fidélisation des personnels soignants
ces difficultés sont liées à plusieurs
facteurs externes bien identifié sur
lesquell les établissements n'ont pas de
prise ce déficit est évalué à ,2
milliards d'euros fin
2023 et il a triplé en un an les
conséquences pour les territoires se
font ressentir avec notamment un
allongement des délais de paiement pour
les fournisseurs locaux et une
fragilisation profonde des opérations
d'investissement des mesures d'urgence
Monsieur le Premier Ministre permettront
sûrement de rectifier cette tendance
négative de même la mise en place d'une
stratégie de financement à long terme
pour continuer à investir innover et
soigner et nécessaire pour nos hôpitaux
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nos
hôpitaux sont un ont été un bouclier
sanitaire pendant la crise récente et
resturont le socle de notre système de
soins Monsieur le Premier Ministre
allez-vous activer ces leviers et tous
les leviers nécessaires pour aider nos
établissements de soins à évoluer avec
sérénité
merci pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre du
Travail de la santé et des solidarités
Madame Catherine Vautrin vous avez la
parole madame la ministre merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur califé
merci monsieur le sénateur d'avoir bien
voulu rappeler toute l'importance que le
gouvernement de Gabriel Atal attache au
phénomène de la santé et
particulièrement à l'hôpital la semaine
dernière dans son discours de politique
général monsieur le Premier ministre a
rappelé combien l'hôpital était notre
joyau hier je recevais le Pr président
de la FHF et sa directrice générale et
bien évidemment avec eux je faisais un
tour d'horizon sur l'ensemble des sujets
de l'hôpital et comme vous j'ai pris
connaissance du courrier adressé par les
élus puisque ce sont les maires qui sont
présidents des conseils de surveillance
des établissements alors je partage en
grande partie ce que vous avez bien
voulu rappeler le rôle de l'hôpital dans
notre pays et l'implication des
personnels et le retour d'attractivité
parce que la l' année 23 a été très
significative sur plus d'attractivité la
meilleure preuve le nombre de
recrutements notamment d'infirmière a
augmenté ensuite effectivement nous
sommes confrontés à un sujet financier
le gouvernement avait déjà participé à
apporter des réponses c'était le sujet
du segégur en matière de financement
avec l'augmentation des personnels et
c'est vous l'avez évoqué également le
segure investissement avec les travaux
de modernisation pour autant
effectivement il y a un sujet en fin
d'année nous n'avons pas encore
totalement la clôture de l'exercice 23
mais nous savons qu'il faut accompagner
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le Premier ministre nous a
accompagné avec nos équipes et dans les
jours qui viennent nous serons en mesure
d'apporter des réponses des réponses sur
les sujets de sous-exécution et des
réponses financières qui permettront un
d'assumer les charges y compris
vis-à-vis des fournisseurs locaux mais
qui permettront également de mettre en
œuvre l'investissement pour plus de
modernisation donc plus de conditions de
travail et plus d'accessibilité aux
soins dans notre
pays monsieur califé
califé merci merci madame la ministre
pour cette réponse qui qui me qui me
convient parfaitement vous appliquer ici
une règle que j'aime beaucoup les amours
c'est bien mais les preuves d'amour
c'est encore mieux merci
bien la parole est à notre collègue
chiling pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progistes et
indépendants merci merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur le ministre nous partageons
tous ici une conviction l'agriculture
est constitutive de notre identité nous
sommes fiers de nos agriculteurs de leur
engagement passionnés et nous ne pouvons
être qu'à l'écoute de leur revend iation
légitime dans mon département du haurin
j'ai rencontré comme chacun ici de
nombreux agriculteurs qui m'ont fait
part de leurs difficultés et surtout de
leur sentiment de ne pas être entendu
frein administratif concurrence déloyale
et surtout faiblesse de leurs revenus
c'est le ralbol qu'ils ont exprimé en 30
ans ce revenu a chuté de 40 % en France
bien loin de refléter les efforts la
passion et le travail qu'ils fournissent
au quotidien avec les lois égalim 1 et 2
le gouvernement a courageusement porté
nous avons répondu à une partie des
inquiétudes de nos agricultteur en
inversant la construction du prix mais
l'application de ces lois n'est pas
satisfaisante monsieur le ministre mon
groupe a accueilli avec satisfaction
l'annonce du doublement des contrôles
que votre administration va mener mais
les sanctions à prévoir pour ceux qui ne
les respectent pas les règles ne
changeront pas à elle seul la situation
pour nos agriculteurs nous devons
veiller à l'application pérenne des lois
égalimes nous le devons à nos
agriculteurs pour améliorer leur
quotidien et pour faire en sorte que
leur travail soit justement reconnu
monsieur le ministre comment renforcer
l'application des lois égalim afin que
les négociations commerciales soient
équilibrées et que chacun puisse vivre
dignement de son travail je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur Bruno leci
monsieur le
président madame la
sénatrice Patricia
chilinger je partage totalement ce que
vous venez de dire sur le revenu des
producteurs c'est évidemment le combat
essentiel je l'ai mené comme ministre de
l'Agriculture pendant 3 ans je le mène
comme ministre d'économie et des
Finances avec le Premier ministre et
avec le ministre l'agriculture marque
Phen il y a pas d'agriculture sans
paysans il y a pas de paysan sans
revenus décent et le revenus décent il
doit être garanti par le strict respect
des lois é Gal nous avons donc lancé à
la fin des négociations commerciales
elles ont pris fin le 31 janvier un
doublement des contrôles la direction
générale la consommation la répression
des fraudes sur 1000 contrats concernant
75 des plus gros industriells et les 5
distributeurs sur ces 1000 contrats 124
ne respectent pas pour des raisons de
calendrier notamment les dispositions de
la loi égalime j'ai donc lancé les
injonction à l'ensemble des
distributeurs et des industriels qui ne
respectent pas les règles ils ont 15
jours pour fournir des explications ou
s'y conformer faute de quoi chacun
encourra une sanction de 5 millions
d'euros par infraction et croyez-moi
nous n'aurons pas la main qui tremble
les sanctions tomberont sur tous les
distributeurs et tous les industriels
qui n'auraient pas respecté strictement
et rigoureusement les dispositions de la
loi etgaline deuxième chose ces
dispositions s'appliquent à toutes les
négociation qu'elles aient eu lieu en
France ou qu'elles ai eu lieu par
l'intermédiaire des centrales d'achat
européennes un produit qui est vendu en
France doit respecter toutes les
dispositions de la loi égalim même s'il
a été négocié par l'intermédiaire de ces
fameuses centrales d'achat européenes
j'y veillerai aussi et j'ai aussi doublé
les contrôles sur ces centrales d'achat
européennes et sur les négociations qui
ont eu lieu enfin troisème chose sur
laquelle nous veillons particulièrement
c'est la tromperie du consommateur qui
est aussi le vol du producteur quand
vous avez un poulet sur lequel vous avez
un étiquetage avec un drapeau tricolore
c'est une tromperie du consommateur et
c'est un vol du producteur qui lui c'est
Chine à travailler à cultiver à produire
en France sur le territoire français
avec les normes françaises et avec les
réglementations française là aussi nous
avons multiplié les contrôles les
industriels qui s'amusent à mettre des
drapeaux tricolor sur les produits qui
viennent de l'étranger s'expose à une
sanction qui pourra aller jusqu'à 15 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires là aussi les
sanctions tomberont et personne ne
passera entre les mailles du
filet donne la parole notre collègue
Pierre jeanochet pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre le cors
nu mes chers collègues vous devez
comprendre que si l'Europe est attaquée
nous ne viendrons jamais pour vous aider
et vous soutenir ces propos surprenants
sont ceux du président américain Donald
Trump tenu à Ursula von derleen la
présidente de la Commission européenne
en 2020 Thierry Breton ne pouvait pas
inciter davantage les Européens à bâtir
la défense européenne qu'en nous
rappelant ses paroles une des condition
cineéquanon à cela est d'avoir une
France forte et capable sur le plan
militaire on dit que Poutine a
ressuscité l'OTAN en envahissant
l'Ukraine il est vrai que deux pays
scandinaves ont manifesté leur souhait
de rejoindre l'organisation après des
décennies de désengagements un effort
budgétaire massif s'opère partout en
Europe mais dans quelques mois si Donald
Trump est réélu gagne les élections que
vaudra encore l'Alliance atlantique
au-delà des nouvelles adhésions nous
devons absolument nous pencher sur nos
capacités la question des munitions est
un enjeu crucial de la guerre de haute
intensité chaque jour les Ukrainiens
tirent entre 5 à 8000 obus quand les
Russes tirent exactement le double les
États européens se sont engagés à
soutenir l'effort de guerre ukrainien et
à livrer à Kiev 1 million d'obut
c'est-à-dire au mieux 6 mois de munition
nous ne tiendrons pas cet engagement
nous espérons tout juste pouvoir
atteindre la moitié et livrer un peu
plus de 500000 obus avant fin mars
pourquoi parce que nous n'en produisons
pas assez mais aussi parce que nous
continuons collectivement d'en exporter
au bénéfice de pays qui ont bien moins
qui en ont bien moins besoin que
l'Ukraine monsieur le ministre il est
grand temps d'intensifier le le soutien
de notre pays à l'Ukraine et de nos
réarmées où en est l'économie de guerre
annoncée par le président Macron merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre des Armées monsieur le corn
vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président du
SDA mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le le sénateur sur la question
que vous posez sur l' on aura d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'y revenir dans le cadre des
travaux de la commission Affaires
étrangères et défens puisque le
président Perin à la suite du président
Cambon ont décidé justement de revenir
sur la question de la place de la France
au sein de l'OTAN il y a quand même une
réalité on le voit bien qu'il nous faut
travailler avec les différents
partenaires européens y compris la
Grande-Bretagne par son modèle d'armée
par l'pport de sa dissuasion nucléaire
évidemment pour l'ensemble continental
il nous faudra évidemment continuer à
nous réarmer c'est le sens de de
programmation militaire que vous avez
voté sur la question de l'aide à raine
et au fond notre économie de guerre vous
le voyez bien on est passé d'une logique
de cession sur les stocks de nos armées
à une logique de production pour
évidemment continuer de soutenir l'armée
ukrainienne dans la guerre qu'elle mène
suite à l'agression russe cette remontée
en puissance elle est indispensable y
compris pour nous-mêmes dans les
différents conflits que nous pouvons
connaître elle est indispensable parce
que cette perte de musces industriel
s'expliqué évidemment pour le contexte
stratégique lié à la fin de la guerre
froide malheureusement aussi monsieur le
sénateur lié au diminution de crédit
budgétaire pour les forces armées
pendant pratiquement plus de 15 ans qui
ont évidemment conduit à une perte de
commande et donc à une réorganisation
dans le mauvais sens de notre industrie
et si les crédits augmentent depuis 2017
ça reprend du temps évidemment de monter
en puissance bon pour répondre
précisément à votre question l'économie
de guerre en tout cas la reprise de la
production par nos industrielle est en
cours elle profite très directement à
l'Ukraine je pense qu'il y a un certain
nombre de résultats qui sont là par
exemple l'entreprise Tales où il fallait
24 mois pour produire un radar désormais
il faut 6 mois MBDA les missilees
Mistral sur la défense solaire il
fallait 24 mois c'est désormais 15 mois
je pense que le résultat autour du canon
César nexxter est évidemment à saluer 30
mois pour produire un canon César divisé
par 2 15 mois et je ve viment remercier
les équipes de ces entreprises parce que
derrière ce n'est pas que de
l'organisationnel c'est aussi une
augmentation du temps de travail des 38
des entreprises et des salariés des
ouvriers des ingénieurs qui sont engagés
pour permettre justement de relever ce
défi les munitions évidemment là aussi
les résultats sont là notamment pour les
Obut 15 55 mm l'enjeu c'est d'avancer
sur ce qui justement a pris du retard
les missiles Aster les missiles
complexes Aster 15 Aster 30 qui sont
évidemment indispensable pour l'Ukraine
dans la protection de son ciel j'aurai
l'occasion d'evenir devant vous
prochainement
monsieuroch merci merci monsieur le
ministre pour votre réponse écoutez nous
comptons sur vous pour maintenir
l'effort et continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine
merci la parole est à notre
collèged pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre Béchu ch
chers collègues en 2017 le chef d'État
chef de l'État s'était engagé à ce que
plusieurs personnes ne dorment dans la
rue 6 ans plus tard les derniers
chiffres de la Fondation abépierre sont
alarmants et font état de 330000 sans
abri parmi eux une proportion croissante
de femmes et d'enfants il est primordial
de comprendre les parcours de vie qui
conduisent ces personnes à se retrouver
sans domicile fixe et les raisons
peuvent être multiples la perte d'un
emploi des difficultés financières des
problèmes de santé mental des ruptures
familiales ou encore des situations de
violence domestique ces personnes
vulnérables se trouvent exposé à
l'insécurité de la rue et à des
conditions de vie très précaes les
centres d'hébergement sont surplés les
services sociaux sont débordés et les
programmes d'aide sont insuffisants
environ une personnes sur deux qui
contactent le 115 ne se voit proposer
aucune solution d'hébergement ayant Mo
même pris l'initiative d'appeler le 115
en quête d'une solution pour une
personne en grande difficulté je n'ai
malheureusement obtenu aucune
proposition concrète cette situation
souligne les lacunes de notre système
actuel il est du devoir de l'État de
trouver des solutions et de mobiliser
les ressources nécessaires pour résoudre
cette crise sociale grandissante nous
devons augmenter de manière
significative le nombre d'hébergements
d'urgence et d'envisager de
réquisitionner les logements vacants
afin de fournir une solution d'urgence
et de et temporaire pour les sansabris
et prévenir les situation d'extrême
vulnérabilité il est primordial de
coordonner les actions des différentses
acteurs impliqués tels que les services
sociaux les associations caritatives et
les collectivités locales qui se
trouvent souvent seules sur le terrain
monsieur le ministre lors du discours de
politique générale du Premier ministre
aucune motion n'a été faite à cette
problématique majeure ce qui soulève des
interrogations j'aimerais donc obtenir
des informations concernant les mesures
spécifiques que le Gouvernement compte
prendre pour remédier à cette situation
quels sont les projets en cour à avenir
visant à augmenter le nombre de places
dans les hébergements d'urgence que
comptez-vous faire pour renforcer les
programmes d'aide au sans-abri et
améliorer améliorer l'accès aux services
sociaux merci monsieur le ministre de
vos réponses pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre la cohésion des
territoires de la transition écologique
monsieur Béchu vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur
lawedge votre question elle fait
effectivement écho à ce rapport du
mallogement présenté par la Fondation
avpierre la semaine dernière
à l'occasion du 70e anniversaire de
l'appel lancé précisément en 1954 les
chiffres on les connaî on a eu
l'occasion de les rappeler ils sont
présentés dans ce rapport 330000 non pas
sans abri mais mal logé ou sans domicile
et en face l'État a mis en place des
moyens qui sont sans précédent 3
milliards d'euros avec deux types de
dispositifs 203000 places d'urgence un
record et 114000 places dans le cadre du
dispositif national d'accueil quand on
additionne ces deux chiffres et qu'on
les rapproche des 330000 on voit qu'on a
un écart d'une dizaine de milliers de
places et si le premier ministre n'en a
pas parlé c'est parce que tout début du
mois de janvier le 8 janvier Patrice
verrit avait annoncé le déblocage au nom
du gouvernement d'une nouvelle enveloppe
de 120 millions d'euros représentant
l'équivalent d'une dizaine de milliers
de places
mais monsieur le sénateur laouette je
n'ai pas entendu dans votre question la
volonté d'avoir des réponses
arithmétiques ce que vous avez convoqué
ce sont bien des situations humaines
c'est à la fois le désarroi de
travailleurs sociaux pour lesquels ça
n'est pas satisfaisant de se retrouver
sans solution et puis ces femmes ces
hommes ses histoires d'érance ses
difficultés et avec au-delà des
statistiques une attente qui n'est pas
seulement un toit pour une nuit mais qui
est d'avoir des solution le plan
logement d'abord ce sont 550000
logements qui ont été réalis au cours de
ces dernières années plus de la moitié
ont été attribués à des gens qui étaient
sans domicile devant nous il faut qu'on
continue avec le tissu d'acteur à agir
mais il faut aussi en parallèle que nous
regardions en face le fait que face à
cette situation pour accueillir mieux
nous devons sans doute accueillir moins
et c'est aussi la suite à la fois de
décisions qui ont été prises de textes
qui ont été votés et de ce que nous
aurons à mettre en œuvre dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
la parole est à notre collègue adelsiane
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bu depuis 2017 les crises se
multiplient dans notre pays gilets
jaunes retraite les émeutes urbaines le
monde agricole il y a quelques jours
mais actuellement une crise a atteint un
point de NS retour c'est celle du
logement et en particulier du logement
social 70 ans après l'appel de de la baé
pierre vous en parliez votre
responsabilité est immense et vos
réponses ne sont aujourd'hui pas la
hauteur pas la hauteur au moment où le
rapport annuel de la Fondation dont vous
parliez a présenté des chiffres
dramatiques 12 millions de personnes
fragilisé par la crise du logement 4
millions de personnes mal ou non logé 1
million de personnes dans un habitat D
et plus de 300000 personnes sans
domicile en France pas à la hauteur
également au moment où nous n'avons
toujours pas de ministre du Logement
peut-être prochainement et pas à la
hauteur enfin quand le Premier ministre
dans son discours de politique générale
aura à peine consacré 3 minutes à ce
sujet extrêmement important pour nous
annoncer avec une consternation partagée
par l'ensemble des acteurs concernés les
maires des grandes ville-de-fance qui
vous ont fait une lettre ouverte à ce
sujet les associations de locataires de
solidarité les spécialistes de
l'immobilier consternation donc avec
cette proposition de modifier le calcul
SRU pour y intégrer les logements libres
intermédiaires tour de passp statistique
qui va casser le thermomètre de la
mixité sociale et aura un impact quasi
nul voire négatif sur la production de
logements sociaux dans notre pays ma
question est simple comptez-vous
abandonner cette proposition enfin
mettre en œuvre une politique
volontariste ambitieuse en matière de
logement dans notre
pays pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur BCH
monsieur sénateur
zan votre question n'est pas non plus
tout à fait à la hauteur du moment
elle ne l'est pas parce que à vous
entendre parce qu'à vous entendre à vous
entendre et la démocratie c'est le
respect il y aura une crise qui
frapperait notre pays on serait sur un
ilo de déstabilisation et de difficultés
quand dans tous les pays aujourd'hui
sous l'effet de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et de l'augmentation des coûts
de construction les matériaux ont
conduit et ont entraîné une baisse de la
production en Allemagne où vos amis sont
en responsabilité la baisse des mises en
genantier est comparable à celle de la
France en Chine aux États-Unis partout
alors dire qu' nous aurions un problème
français sinement c'est passé à côté
d'une forme de responsabilité de vous
pointez du doigt le fait que le
gouvernement ne répondrait pas en étant
à la hauteur les mesures que nous avons
prises si elles n'ont pas permis
d'enrayer la crise elles ont permis de
la juguler dans un domaine un où le
recul est moins important que dans les
autres c'est précisément sur le logement
social la baisse de construction sur
logement social est deux fois moins
importante et ce qui a le moins reculé
c'est le trait social pourquoi parce
qu'avec le plafonnement du taux du livr
à 3 % avec les programmes de rachat qui
ont été décidés par CDC habitat pour le
compte du gouvernement et par Action
Logement nous avons limité ensuite à
vous entendre il y aurait une forme de
ségrégation sociale qui considérerait
que tout ce qui n'est pas essu n'est pas
digne d' l'année dernière de lli se sont
faites au bénéfice de gens qui sont sous
les plafonds des lls en région
parisienne sur les 3000 pardon sur les
4500 attributions le revenu moyen des
couples était de 36 100 € pour un couple
avec de enfants à ce niveaulà on n'est
pas dans les classes supérieures on a le
droit de se retrouver avec une solution
la volonté de construire des parcours
résidentiels de regarder comment nous
soutenons des m bâtisseurs et nous
recontinuons et nous reconstituons un
continuum d'offre c'est la solution à
laquelle on doit s'atteler tous ensemble
au-delà des anathèmes audelà des
chiffres en mesurant que le problème est
plus large et pour le résoudre il faut
l'état il faut les collectivités locales
et il faut les
banques
monsieur le ministre pas de gêne pas de
réponse à l'ambiqué mais surtout pas de
dénis c'est un point extrêmement
important puisque depuis le début de ce
quinquena et le précédent je le rappelle
depuis 2017 baisse des aides au
locataires au bailleurs sociaux à
l'accession à la propriété production de
logements sociaux en chute libre divisé
par de entre 2023 et 2024 pas de soutien
financier de l'État ni d'objectif de
construction les réponses existent
monsieur le ministre relance de la
production de logement sociaux accession
à la propriété ces réponses elles sont
urgentes elles vous ont été soumises par
tous les acteurs du secteur que vous
avez convoqué lors du Conseil national
de la refondation logement nous vous le
demandons Monsieur le Ministre enfin il
faut prendre à balcore le logement cœur
de la cohésion sociale de notre pays je
vous
remercie la
parole est à notre collègue Pascal
Savoldelli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste canaki
merci merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
avec respect et avec sincérité je vais
vous exprimer un coup de
colère un coup de colère parce que je
suis dans un département où nous avons
dépassé les 100000 demandeurs de
logement un coup de colère parce que 12
millions de personnes fragilisées par la
crise du logement c'est 12 millions de
sinistrés oui c'est une bombe sociale à
retardement la vérité c'est que dès 2017
vos politiques n'ont été qu'un jacuse du
logement social pour libérer toute
contrainte le marché privé baisse des
aPL dès l'élection du président Macron
ponction de 1,3 milliards d'euros dans
les caisses des bailleurs sociaux loilan
pour obliger à vendre des logements
sociaux à la découpe et faire
disparaître les petits bailleurs la loi
casbariant berger pour faciliter les
expulsions et nous voilà désormais à
démelé la loi de solidarité de
renouvellement urbain monsieur le
ministre le bilan est dramatique il n'y
a plus de politique publique du logement
en France pour les acteurs du secteur de
nombreux emplois sont menacés et la
majorité des habitants de notre pays est
livré elle-même face à à la spéculation
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre 56 % d'augmentation des loyers
dans le parc privé Stop ou Encore 2000
enfants à la rue stop ou encore à quand
l'état d'urgence du
logement
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur
salvelli avec respect avec dignité je
vais répondre à votre crit de colère
dont je mesure totalement la sincérité
mais la même sincérité elle doit
conduire à regarder les choses en face
nous n'avons pas une solution du
logement nous avons des solutions on a
3,5 millions de logements vacants dans
notre pays pas forcément aux endroits où
il y a les tensions on a des endroits
qui continuent de construire queles que
soient les couleurs politiques et on a
des endroits où la pression des
habitants sur le fait de ne pas avoir de
voisins conduit à une diminution du
nombre des permis de construire qui a
anticipé une partie des difficultés que
nous connaissons celui qui vous parle il
a 36,94 % de logement social dans sa
ville le rythme de construction de ces
dernières années a Angé il a été plus
important que celui des villes de Nantes
et de reen c'est bien la preuve que tout
ne dépend pas que des circonstances
nationales en revanche par rapport à ce
que vous êtes en train de dire oui oui
il faut une forme d'union sacrée autour
des élus autour du fait d'aller
simplifier une partie des normes qui
explique une partie de ses coûts autour
du fait de se demander comment on rend
du pouvoir d'achat immobilier à des
classes moyennes parce que nous avons un
entassement des demandes de logement qui
sont liés à la difficulté d'accès à la
propriété et c'est à la fois le sens du
choc d'offre que le que le premier
ministre a pu annoncer et des travaux
que nous lançons au sein du ministère de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires avec Bruno Le
Maire pour expertise en particulier le
crédit Infiné le crédit hypothécaire qui
sont des dispositifs qui dans des pays
voisins ont permis d'aller soulager ou
relancer une partie de ces difficultés
le logement social faut qu'on garde le
sujet en face au congrès de l'USH 1,2
milliards d'annonces de soutien le vote
ici dans cet hémicycle d'un dispositif
de deuxème vie parce que nous avons
aussi des logements qui ne sont pas sur
le marché parce qu'ils nécessitent des
travaux de rénovation énergétique que
nous devons conduire donc
oui à l'union sacrée oui à la
mobilisation de crédit sans précédent
c'est le cas pour l'hébergement
d'urgence oui à la relance avec
l'ensemble des acteurs décembre plus 22
% de mise en chantier plus 7 % de dépôts
de permis de construire la stabilisation
des taux du livra et de l'inflation nous
laisse penser que nous sommes
précisément dans la situation où nous
pouvons avec un choc d'offre inverser
les choses parce que nous croyons la
nécessité d'un logement pour tous d'une
France avec l'espoir d'être propriétaire
pour ce qu'ils peuvent et de logements
sociaux dans des taux suffisants partout
sur le
territoire merci
monsieur
Savoldelli faute de ministre du Logement
je vais m'adresser à vous Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
oui nous appons à déclarer l'état
d'urgence national du logement sur 5
axes moratoire sur les expulsions
encadrement des prix du foncier plan
pour les primau accédants relève du
niveau de production et réquisition
nationale des logements vides pour cela
encore faudrait-il avoir une ou un
ministre du Logement Monsieur le Premier
Ministre l'abbé Pierre disait gouverner
c'est d'abord loger son peuple vous êtes
le chef du gouvernement alors maintenant
vraiment
gouverner la parole est au président
Laurent la pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
déclaré la semainnière que pour
préserver l'audiovisuel public il faut
rassembler les forces en un pôle
puissant vos propos rappellent les
travaux d'un de vos prédécesseurs Franck
rester qui avait présenté en Conseil des
ministres un projet de loi autorisant la
création d'une hing pour chapauter tous
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel public
malheureusement la crise de la covid a
arrêté à l'Assemblée nationale les débat
sur ce texte et vos deux prédécesseurs
Roseline Bachelot puis rimd n'ont pas
souhaité reprendre ce
projet faisant preuve d'une certaine
crainte pour ne pas dire étant un peu
timoré sur le sujet des coopérations
dans le secteur de l'audiovisuel public
le Sénat qui préconise cette ligne
depuis 2015 a voté en juin dernier une
proposition de loi que j'avais déposé
qui était rapportée par jean-rmond
Hugonet autorisant enfin cette holding
c'est pour nous le plus sûr moyen de
renforcer l'audio public l'audiovisuel
public dans un secteur doublement
concurrencié concurrencé par les acteurs
du net mais aussi concurrencé par les
plateformes américaines il est
nécessaire en effet de rendre pérenes et
définitive ces coopérations à travers
une gouvernance commune et des actions
concrètes dans les fonctions support
mais aussi dans l'investissement dans
les nouvelles technologies en
particulier l'intelligence artificiel
alors madame la ministre pour renforcer
ces coopérations il y a trois
possibilités la première c'est les
conventions d'objectifs et des moyens
tels que l'État le met en œuvre depuis
plusieurs années et dont on sait
maintenant qu'elles sont inefficace la
deuxème c'est la holding dont je viens
de parler et la troisème c'est la fusion
entre chacune des entités du secteur de
l'audiovisuel public madame la ministre
ma question est simple elle est double
quel est le scénario que vous
privilégiez pour se créer ce pôle
puissant que vous appelez et quel est
votre
calendrier vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre de la Culture madame
Rach vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président la fond je crois
que la réponse est dans votre question
je m'associe à tous vos arguments
d'abord c'est vrai et je l'ai dit et je
le disais d'ailleurs bien avant ma
nomination comme ministre de la Culture
nous avons besoin d'un audiovisuel
public puissant ça c'est une réalité je
sais aussi monsieur le Président puisque
nous avons eu quelques échanges que nous
partageons plusieurs convictions sur ce
sujet alors l'adoption et et vous l'avez
rappelé en juin dernier de votre
proposition de loi relative à la réforme
de l'audiovisuel public et la
souveraineté audiovisuelle évidemment en
témoigne évidemment je m'appuiererai sur
ces travaux alors bien sûr il y a votre
texte mais aussi il y a de nombreux
travaux réalisés d'ailleurs je je les ai
consulté avant mes interventions par qui
ont été réalisé par le Sénat comme le
rapport des sénateurs kucci et Hugonet
publié en
2022 excellent rapport carucciugonet
et le rapport de 2015 des excellents
tout aussi excellents sénateurs gatolin
et le leu
alors alors risque du vous l'avez vous
les avez vous l'avez rappelé sur les
enjeux et C environnement très perturbé
avec tous ces bouleversements
technologiques l'uniformisation des
contenus par les grandes plateformes
internationales la désinformation sur
les réseaux l'irruption de
l'intelligence artificielle tous ces
enjeux là évidemment vous les aviez
intégrés alors c'est vrai il ne faut pas
se dérober et il faut pouvoir répondre à
ces en jeux cruciaux alors moi je plaide
pour un audiovisuel public qui rassemble
toutes ses forces ça correspond
évidemment à votre texte je sais que ces
attentes il y a des attente très forte
sur ces sujets alors moi j'avancerai en
concertation évidemment avec vous je
m'appuierai je le dis ici je l'avais pas
précisé au paravant je m'appuierai sur
votre texte et sur votre PPL monsieur le
Président la fond et également avec vous
sénateurs mais aussi sans exclure aucun
autre intervenant et notamment vos
collègues députés et les grands sujets
pareil nous les aborderons de manière
très précise et de manière assumée quels
sont-ils notamment le financement du
service public de l'audiovisuel mais
j'avais déjà donné mes convictions bien
avant et je rencontrerai je vous l'ai
dit les les dirigeants de des sociétés
très bientôt et nous nous reverrons
évidemment pour lancer ses travaux
ensemble et je vous le redis on ne se
dér
p
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean-rimond Hugonet pour le groupe les
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Culture il y a quelques
jours vous avez indiqué votre souhait
d'incarner une culture populaire et
ouverte sur tout les Français vous avez
même ajouté je cite ma vie s'est
construite avec l'audiovisuel public dès
lors pourquoi ne pas commencer votre
action par l'audiovisuel qui attend une
réforme depuis si longtemps en effet la
loi de 86 relative à l'ensemble de
l'audiovisuel est à bout de souffle
l'absence de pluralisme et de réforme du
service public menace le consensus
national sur la nécessité de lui
accorder plus de financement la
réglementation de la production enrichie
des fonds d'investissement américains
qui ont mis la main sur de nombreux
producteurs français et j'en passe
est-ce que la déburaucratisation promise
par Monsieur monieur le Premier ministre
a vocation à s'arrêter aux portes de
l'audiovisuel français est-ce que la
maîtrise de la dépense publique est
condamnée à ne pas concerner
l'audiovisuel public dernière adepte du
quoi qu'il en coûte est-ce que le
principe de libre entreprise est obligé
de ne pas s'appliquer à nos chaînes
privées entravé par des réglementations
surabondantes quiignorent les
plateformes américaines en un mot madame
la ministre est-ce que les propositions
constante du Sénat depuis 2015 sont voué
à être toujours salués mais rarement
appliqué par des locataires de la rue de
Valois d'autant plus applaudis lors de
leur départ que leur bilan aura été
minuscule la proposition de loi de mon
collègue et amis le président Laurent
Laffond dont je fus le rapporteur adopté
par le Sénat il y a quelques mois
constitue une base solide pour avancer
pouvez-vous nous préciser vos intentions
et surtout votre calendrier madame la
ministre dans ce domaine pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre de la Culture madame dti vous
avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hugonet j'allais dire je vais
reprendre la réponse que je viens de
faire au président la
fond je vais faire simple je vais
reprendre la PPL vous avez raison ça
c'est la première chose dès que possible
alors vous avez raison parfois on
applaudit les bilans maigres puis
parfois on applaudis pas quand le bilan
est réel j'en sais quelque chose alors
je vous le dis évidemment je vous
évidemment je travaillerai avec vous
évidemment c'est une non c'est pas non
c'est pas ça c'est une réalité
malheureusement c'est une réalité
simplement le sujet est trop sérieux
vous avez raison pour le différer encore
une fois les enjeux sont lourds il faut
effectivement un audiovisuel public
puissant et très fort et sans réforme je
crois que effectivement les contrats
d'objectif je trouve que c'est une
mauvaise ça n'a pas si bien marché que
ça je je le reconnais et sur le
calendrier on va démarer ensemble on va
essayer évidemment il faut consulter
tous les acteurs pour qu'on puisse mais
je crois aussi que du côté de
l'audiovisuel public ils ont aussi
avancé sur cette volonté aussi de réfme
de réforme sur le financement mais aussi
sur la gouvernance notamment sur les
coopérations renforcées et j'allais dire
même sur la gouvernance unique et sur la
fusion notamment des réseaux de
proximité qui a un peu commencé mais qui
n'a pas été abouti et donc nous allons
la poursuivre pour la mettre en œuvre
sur la gouvernance sur le financement ce
sont des enjeux cruciaux que nous
mettrons en euh en œuvre ensemble je
vous remercie monsieur
Hugonet merci monsieur le Président nous
avons entendu madame la ministre votre
volonté d'ouvrir le débat quant à
l'avenir de l'audiovisuel il y a urgence
car nous devons nous pencher dès la fin
de l'année sur l'avenir de son
financement notamment autant le dire
clairement les conditions ne sont pas
réunies aujourd'hui pour accorder un
blancin sous la forme d'une modification
de la loi organique seule une réforme
d'envergure garantissant le pluralisme
et réformant la gouvernance pour
pourrait justifier une telle évolution
nous sommes à votre disposition ici au
Sénat vous avez souligné l'excellence
des travaux du Sénat dans ce domaine
nous sommes
disponibles
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Marion
Canales pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
la France n'est pas assez riche de ses
enfants pour en négliger un seul telle
était la première phrase du premier
texte signé par le général de Gaulle à
la Libération entre 2017 et 2019 pas de
ministre chargé de la protection de
l'enfance et nous attendons depuis des
semaines la composition du gouvernement
il a fallu une succession de drame pour
que le Président de la République se
rende compte que la protection de
l'enfance exigeait un pilotage politique
en 2019 de la même façon vous avez
attendu Monsieur le Premier Ministre
qu'un autre drame humain se déroule dans
mon département le puit de dôme avec le
suicide d'une enfant d'à peine 15 ans
placé pour prendre enfin les décrets
d'application d'une loi voté il y a 2
ans à la hâte hier soir dont l'encre est
encore peu sèche et dont les contours
nous sont encore inconnus face à
l'inercie de votre gouvernement les
inquiétudes et colères légitimes se
multiplient et vous devez les entendre
on ront nous demain un ministre de
l'enfance et de la protection de
l'enfance doter des moyens financiers
pour initier enfin un plan Marchal de la
protection de l'enfance plus qu'urgent
avec tous les acteurs concernés et
désinvisibiliser ces 350000 enfants
placés et les professionnels qui les
accompagnent sans relâche merci
pour vous répondre la parole ministre du
Travail de la santé des solidarités
madame Vautrin vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Canales merci madame la
sénatrice de rappeler la mémoire de
cette jeune fille aujourd'hui qui est
précisément le 2e anniversaire de la loi
taquet alors c'est vrai qu'il restait
des décrets mais que le premier ministre
arrivé il y a 3 semaines a signé ce
décret et nous savons et nous savons
qu'il est était important nous savons
que ce décret était tout à fait
important puisque pour être très
concrète ce décret est celui qui
interdit le placement d'enfants dans des
établissements commerciaux et ça je
crois que c'est important de le dire
parce que ces enfants qui sont confiés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sont celles et
ceux qui ont le plus besoin d'être
accompagné et l'esprit de la loi taquet
parce que il faut le rappeler c'était
pré précisément de favoriser la parole
de ces enfants que ces enfants soient
écoutés beaucoup en ont parlé cette
majorité l'a fait alors aujourd'hui nous
apportons effectivement des réponses
c'est toujours trop long quand on
s'occupe des enfants mais je voudrais
dire que un c'est fait et deuxièmement
je voudrais souligner le travail que
nous menons avec les départements parce
que ce sont les départements qui au
quotidien sont au côté des
professionnels des enfants et ces
départements ne manquent pas de nous
interpeller parce que nous devons
regarder la situation avec lucidité
après le covid les violences
intrafamiliales ont augmenté elles
appellent des réponses c'est le sens de
notre engagement c'est aussi le sens du
projet de loi de finan pour 2024 qui a
permis un accompagnement financier donc
regardons les progrès mesurons le chemin
à parcourir et mobilisons-nous
ensemble madame
Canales alors il vous reste encore 24
heures pour décider si oui ou non il y
aura un ministère de l'enfance et de la
protection de l'enfance la protection de
l'enfance devait être l'enjeu du
quinquena depuis rien rien de lors de la
de votre déclaration de politique
générale Monsieur le Premier Ministre
rien pour les 350000 enfants placés dont
10000 bébés certainsô atteint du
syndrome de l'hospitalisme rien pour la
santé mentale de ces enfants qui
perdraient 20 ans d'espérance de vie et
font 37 fois plus de dépression et de
tentative de suicide rien sur la
reconnaissance de l'utilité sociale des
professions de la protection de
l'enfance rien pour les départements en
première ligne et qui font face à un
resserement de leurs finances le propre
de la puissance et de protéger disait
pourtant bless Pascal votre gouvernement
semble toujours plus pront à réprimer
qu'à protéger j'en veux pour preuve que
les décrets d'application relatif au
code de la justice pénale des mineurs
ont eux été pris en 3 mois quand il a
fure attendre 2 ans pour la protection
de l'enfance combien encore de drames
avant de tenir la promesse de faire de
la protection de l'enfance une priorité
et un vrai
ministère la parole est à notre collègue
George naturel pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle monsieur le ministre la
filière nickel en Nouvelle-Calédonie
traverse actuellement une crise d'une
rare gravité les trois usines
métallurgiques de KNS de laasln et du
Sud connaissent depuis plusieurs mois
des difficultés majeures et sont au bord
du dépôt de bilan plusieurs milliers
d'emplois directs et indirects sont en
cause et de très nombreuses familles
calédoniennes vivent dans l'angoisse de
lendemain de lendemain particulièrement
difficile la fermeture de l'usine du de
KNS qui est aujourd'hui la plus menacée
avec environ 1300 emplois directs et qui
vaudrait proportionnellement la
fermeture dans l'Hexagone d'un site
industriel de plus de 300000 emplois
lors de votre visite sur place fin
novembre dernier vous avez proposé sous
réserve de trois conditions aux
industriels et aux collectivités
calédoniennes un Pact nickel pour sauver
chacune des usines en fixant à fin
janvier 2024 la date limite de sa
signature cette échéance est aujourd'hui
dépassée et aucun Pact na encore été
signé alors que la situation ne cesse de
s'aggraver monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer précisément
quel est à ce jour l'état des
négociations de ce ce pacte nickel pour
chacune des des usines avez-vous obtenu
de la part des actionnaires eramè pour
la SLN Glencore pour knns et Trafigura
pour l'usine du Sud les engagements que
vous demandez avez-vous obtenu l'accord
de tous les élus calédonien pour que les
ressources minières soient mieux
valorisées quand allez-nous allez-vous
annoncer pour chacune des usines le
montant et la date du déblocage des
prèrelais de l'État et enfin quand
allez-vous annoncer les modal le
calendrier du soutien de l'État pour
moderniser la production électrique et
réduire son coût pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur naturel je
partage totalement votre diagnostic sur
l'état de la filière nickel en
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui est confronté à
la fois à une compétition nouvelle de la
part de l'Indonésie de la Corée du Sud
de la Chine
qui produisent à des coûts bien
inférieurs et un effondrement du cours
du nickel les deux mettent les trois
usines cell du Sud celle de Na et celle
du Nord en grande difficulté je me suis
rendu sur place avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur géralanin il y a quelques
semaines pour faire le point avec
l'ensemble des acteurs les élus et les
industriels j'ai dit à quel point je
croyais dans l'avenir de la filière
nickel en Nouvelle Calédonie le nickel
fait partie de l'avenir économique de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais pour que nous
puiss ouvrir des perspectives il y a
trois conditions que je rappelle la
première c'est effectivement conclure ce
Pact nickel avec l'ensemble des élus
locaux pour mieux exploiter la ressource
minière donner de la visibilité sur
cette exploitation et permettre
l'exploitation des minerais qui ne sont
pas utilisé parce que ça fait de la
trésorerie pour les industries elles en
ont bien besoin ce pacte nickel la
négociation progresse j'ai bon espoir
que nous puissions parvenir à une
signature définitive sous quelques
semaines la deuxème condition c'est que
l'État s'engage sur la rénovation des
réseaux électriques le président de la
République a pris des engagements je
suis chargé de les mettre en œuvre nous
engagerons les investissements
nécessaires pour moderniser le réseau
énergétique calédonien mais il y a une
troisème condition qui est essentielle
il y a pas d'usine sans industriel donc
s'il n'y a pas d'industriel pour opérer
les usines cela ne peut pas marcher pour
la seule usine du Nord KNS j'ai proposé
100 millions d'euros de près de l'État
45 millions d'euros d' immédiate 65
millions d'euros de soutien sous une
autre forme financière soit près de 200
millions d'euros de soutien pour une
seule usine donc l'État a fait tout ce
qu'il devait faire pour l'usine KNS du
Nord il a fait le maximum financièrement
maintenant c'est aux actionnaires
c'est-à-dire la province Nord et
Glencore de prendre leur
responsabilité monsieur naturel vous
avez 6 secondes merci en tout cas on
attend avec impatience le résultat de
ces négociations parce que les
Calédoniens ont des aujourd'hui des des
soucis
particuliers
merci la parole est à ellisabeth douanau
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
madame le rapporteur
général merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre messieurs
mesdames les ministres chers collègues
en ce début d'année deux actualités
viennentéclabous et j'emploie ce terme à
dessin le monde des eaux minérales en
France la première est d'ordre sanitaire
puisque c'est une étude américaine qui
déclare que il y aurait 100 fois plus de
nanoparticules dans l'eau minérale que
ce qu'on estimait auparavant donc des
nanoparticules qui circulent dans le
sang qui vont atteindre les organes et
qui vont aller jusque voilà dans notre
cerveau par un petit peu partout la
deuxième est d'ordre économique et
politique c'est pour ça que je m'adresse
à Monsieur le Ministre ministre Bruno Le
Maire parce que deux médias ont annoncé
la semaine dernière qu'en fait des
grands groupes qui produisent des eaux
minérales et bien utilisai des
traitements qui n'étaient pas autorisés
auparavant pour les eau de source or
vous avez autorisé par des arrêtés
préfectoraux ces traitements qui
permettaient que l'eau soit consommable
en quelque sorte mais peut-on considérer
dès lors que ce sont des eau de source
telles qu'elles sont vendues ensuite euh
vous avez aussi diliganté une étude euh
à l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales mais jusqu'à ce jour nous
n'avons pas eu l'ensemble des
conclusions euh que nous disent ces
conclusions parce que finalement cette
eau minérale a été vendue euh 100 fois
plus cher que l'eau du robinet alors que
ce n'était qu'une simple eau du robinet
puisqu'elle subissait les mêmes
traitements que l'eau du robinet alors
Monsieur le Ministre comment avez-vous
pu accepter euh ce euh cette tromperie
du consommateur dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure parce que la tromerie du
consommateur elle ne peut pas être à
géométrie variable et là finalement on a
fait payer à tous les consommateurs le
prix d'une eau du robinet en
bouteille monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances Monsieur
Bruno Le
Maire vous avez parfaitement raison
madame la sénatrice il n'est pas
question qu'il y ait de tromperie de
consommateur pas question qu'il y ait de
manquement à la réglementation donc
lorsque les informations nous sont
remontées les agences régionales de
santé ont saisi le procureur de la
République pour risque de manquement à
la réglementation et trompris du
consommateur une eau minérale doit
respecter un certain nombre de
procédures un certain nombre de règles
vous les avez rappelé donc il est
indispensable que le consommateur ne
soit pas floué et que ces règles soient
respectées l'agence régionale de santé
les agences régionales de santé
d'ailleurs parce que il y a plusieurs
territoires qui ont été concernés ont
saisi au titre de l'article 40 le
procureur de la République une enquête
judiciaire a été ouverte et la direction
générale de la consommation de la
répression des fraudes apporte son
soutien à cette enquête pour examiner si
oui ou non je n'ai évidemment pas la
réponse les industriels ont respecter ou
non les réglementations européennes donc
attendons la fin de l'enquête de justice
c'est l'enquête de justice qui
déterminera si les industriels concernés
ont oui ou non respecté les
réglementations en vigueur mais il va de
soi que si il n'y avait pas de respect
la réglementation là aussi les sanctions
nécessaires s'appliqueraient madame
douanau oui finalement l'autre source
n'est pas généreuse par nature elle est
coûteuse par forfaiture
ah la parole est à notre collègue Anne
chin Larcher pour le groupe les
républicains merci Monsieur le
présidentieur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues sous le feu des médias
la loi visant à lutter contre la
maltraitance animale et conforter le
lien entre les animaux et les hommes a
été promulgué le 30 novembre 2021 loi
réécrite à 85 % au Sénat devenue
coutumier du fait cette loi impacte
entre autres les animaleries les cirques
parcs zoologiques parc aquatiques ces
professionnels sont talentueux
passionnés soucieux du bien-être des
animaux qu'ils hébergent soignent et
étudient depuis 201 les textes
réglementaires concernant les parcs
aquatiques accueillant les mammifères
marins ne sont toujours pas signés
promenés de secrétaire d'État en
secrétaire d'État à la faveur des
remanements ministériels ces parcs n'ont
pas de ligne clair sur le cadre
applicable à leurs activité et de ce
fait aucune assurance qu'elle soit
pérenne ce n'est pas l'esprit de la loi
qui a été votée le coup prè tombera le
1er décembre 2026 c'est-à-dire demain
d'ici là ils devront avoir investi pour
être en conformité à la loi monsieur le
ministre ce que vous imposez à ces
professionnels est inacceptable P
pouvez-vous nous dire quand enfin les
arrêtés concernant les conditions
d'hébergement les contours des
programmes scientifiques et les
démonstrations au public des résultats
des recherches seront
signé pour vous répondre la parole au
ministre de l'Agriculture monsieur merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame
sénatrice Chen Larcher vous êtes très
Mobilis sur très mobilisé pardon sur
cette question vous avez beaucoup
participé aux travaux de cette loi sur
pour lutter contre le la maltraitance
animale je répondrai sur la question des
parcs que vous évoquez mais vous dire
que d'abord un certain nombre de décrets
ont été pris sur les sujets qui étaient
autres je pense au sujet de la vente en
ligne sur lequel le décret a été pris en
le 1er juillet 2023 le décret aussi qui
a été publié sur le certificat
d'engagement et de connaissance qui doit
être demandé à des gens qui sont
détenteurs d'un animal ou qui font
l'acquisition d'un animal de compagnie
qui et puis troisème décret sur la
formation des détenteurs d'animaux ou en
particulier de ceux qui sont en charge
de refuge et qui recueillent des animaux
de compagnie nous avons aussi mis des
moyens importants sur la question des
refuges c'est plus de 30 millions
d'euros qui sont qui sont déployés et
puis la dernière question que vous posez
enfin la question principale que vous
posez elle pose elle relève du registre
ceci étant du ministre de la transition
écologique qui ne pouvait pas être
présent pour la fin de votre question la
question c'est de déplo y et de donner
des signaux aux détenteurs de ses part
pour savoir dans quel cadre ils vont
être fait la question qui est posée est
celle de la du délai le délai c'est dans
les semaines ou les au plus tard dans un
ou de mois de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse leur donner les éléments de
clarification réglementaire pour qu'ils
puissent se préparer à la sortie dans le
cadre de la loi telle qu'elle avait été
prévue l'esprit et la lettre de la loi
telle qu'ils avaient été prévu madame
charcher et vous voyez monsieur le
ministre je suis désolé mais vous n'êtes
pas le bon ministre je m'adressais au
ministre Béchu chargé de la transition
écologique ça fait ça fait des années ça
fait des années que vous baladez ces ces
professionnels en vérité qu'est-ce qu'il
se passe il se passe que il faudrait que
vous disiez d'ailleurs à votre
administration qu'elle arrête de prêter
le flan aux associations animalistes qui
répondent à une idéologie W et qui font
en sorte de déconstruire ce qui a
façonné la France alors ici au Sénat on
peut vous dire que nous sommes à côté de
ces professionnels qui sont notre
patrimoine ils font la fierté de la
France et au Sénat nous veillerons à ce
que la France reste la France
la parole est à notre collègue Hervé
gilet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre madame la
ministre rétention d'information auprès
de la Commission européenne
dissimulation fraude aux consommateurs
non respect de la loi vaste tromperie
voilà les faits qui sont reprochés au au
gouvernement suite aux révélations de
Radio France et du journal Le Monde fin
janvier cette enquête nous informe qu'un
rendez-vous s'est tenu entre nestley
wats et le cabinet de Madame panier
runaché à leur ministre chargé de
l'industrie en
2021 à la suite de cette réunion un
rapport de Ligas a été remis au
gouvernement en
2022 ce rapport serait accablant il n'a
jamais été rendu public depuis 2022 le
gouvernement a donc eu connaissance des
pratiques frauduleuses de C grands
groupes industriels utilisant des
traitements non conformes pour
commercialiser leurs eau de source et
minéral ceci à priori sans informer la
justice ni les consommateurs sur
initiative de mon collègue Alexandre
wiisil nous avons alerté madame la
ministre dès le 31 janvier afin de lever
les doutes sur ce dossier nous sommes
donc en attente avec impatience de la
réponse de Madame la Ministre alors
madame est-ce que vous confirmez les
accusations contenues dans le rapport
d'enquête pourquoi navez pas rendu
public le rapport d'oligas allez-vous
désormais le faire votre gouvernement
a-t-il informé la Commission européenne
comme vous en aviez
l'obligation monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie Monsieur le Maire pour
répondre c'est monsieur qui répond et
pas madame monsieur le sénateur mais je
vous ferai la la même réponse que tout à
l'heure il y a une enquête judiciaire
qui est en cours les agences régionales
de santé ont saisi par l'article 40 le
procureur de la République cette enquête
elle doit déterminer si oui ou non les
industriels deagro alimentaire je
partage totalement votre avis sur la
gravité des faits qui sont reprochés
s'agit de savoir si oui ou non ces
industriels ont respecté les
réglementations au titre des EAU minéral
ou si les procédés qu'ils ont employés
font que ça n'était pas des EAU
minérales ou ça ne répondait pas au
cahier des charges fixées pour les eaux
minérales donc c'est effectivement en
matière de tromppris du consommateur
comm le rappelait madame la Catrice tout
à l'heure un enjeu majeur l'enquête
judiciaire est ouverte la justice a été
saisie par les ARS au titre de l'article
40 la direction générale de la
consommation la répression des fraudes
va apporter son expertise pour
déterminer la conformité ou non de ce
qui a été décidé par les industriels et
la justice rendra sa décision dans les
semaines ou dans les mois qui viennent
donc laissons la justice mener son
enquête jusqu'au bout je pense qu'elle
est la Seu à même désormais à pour
apporter des réponses à vos questions
monsieur
gilet je vous remercie monsieur le
Président euh monsieur le ministre il
faut observer dans cette affaire la
chronologie des faits et vous étiez
informé le gouvernement a été informé
bien longtemps déjà de cette situation
les ARS se sont mobilisés beaucoup plus
tardivement et quand on analysera le
pourquoi elles se sont mobilisées c'est
pas forcément sur votre injonction donc
ça c'est de son d'élément important donc
ce sont des faits qui sont
particulièrement dommageables pour notre
démocratie à la fois en terme de
conivance avec des intérêts privés et
surtout en terme de confiance vis-à-vis
des citoyens et de leur gouvernant il
vous créer quelque part les conditions
d'une société de défiance et de
suspicion pire ce type de comportement
peut alimenter les théories du complot
si vous souhaitez clarifier la situation
vous ne pourrez que soutenir la création
d'une commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur le sujet nous jugerons donc sur les
actes
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Micheline Jacques pour le
complet républicain vous avez la
parole ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'intérieurs et des autres maires
monsieur le ministre notre groupe est
profondément préoccupé par la situation
de chaos dans laquelle vit Mayot et sur
laquelle nos collègues maorés vous
alertent régulièrement du reste la crise
de l'eau R très médiatisé c'est en
réalité ajouté à l'insécurité la
pauvreté l'insalubrité l'immigration
galopante une crise économique et
sociale profonde aux difficultés liées
aux infrastructures
sous-dimensionnées la population excédée
paralyse maotte une nouvelle fois pour
protester contre l'insécurité cette
situation insurrectionnelle n'est pas
plus acceptable à maotte qu'ailleurs
dans notre République rétablir
durablement la sécurité et l'autorité de
l'État ce doit être la priorité des
priorités l'immigration incontrôlée est
à l'origine de la pression démographique
il n'est l'équivalent d'une classe par
jour à la maternité il faut durcir les
règles d'immigration et d'acquisition de
la nationalité en vigueur à Maor à
maotte certes et tarir la source de sa
principale difficulté mais on ne peut
plus se contenter de mesures d'urgence
qui permettent en effet d'apaiser un
temps les tensions on voit bien que l'Î
a besoin d'une vie vision pour adapter
efficacement et structurellement
l'action de l'État et des collectivités
locales à sa réalité et que sans moyen
l'État ne peut pas s'appliquer
efficacement un projet de loi pour un
développement accéléré de Mayotte avait
été annoncé en 2021 nous sommes en 2024
et le désespoir s'empare de la
population aussi eu égard au caractère
multidimensionnel de la crise monsieur
le ministre êtes-vous en mesure de nous
annoncer un plan ou une loi de
programmation pour
Mayotte pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur et les autres
Maes monsieur
[Applaudissements]
dararmin monsieur le Président du du
Sénat mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice vous avez
parfaitement raison Mayot connaît des
difficultés très importantes du fait de
l'immigration du fait de la sécurité du
fait des questions économiques et
sociales mais aussi des transports et
des infrastructures dans des conditions
évidemment d'égalité avec le territoire
depuis que le Président Chirac je
voudrais vous le rappeler a décidé de
faire maotte un département et il nous
appartient désormais de pouvoir tenir
l'engagement du président de la
République ja Chirac dans des conditions
évidemment très difficiles mais vous
connaissez mon engagement profond pour
Mayotte et pour aider l'archipel à
pouvoir mieux vivre mieux vivre d'abord
contre l'immigration irrégulière c'est
le cas depuis l'opération bouchou c'est
le cas aussi avec la construction du 2è
centre de rétention administrative c'est
le cas avec la loi immigration qui
dispose de désormais de moyens
extrêmement important pour lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière à mayott mais
ce qui se passe en ce moment à mayott ce
n'est pas simplement de l'immigration
qui viendrait des Comores ou de
Madagascar mais de l'Afrique des grands
lacs du fait de l'islamisme galopant
dans ces territoire particulier et à
Cavani le camp de d' migration que
connaî maotte et qui a fait exploser si
je dire une colère qui était déjà
évidemment très sourde j'ai pris des
mesures sans précédent d'évacuation d'un
terrain qui appartient au conseil
départemental et pour la première fois
de rapatriement en hexagone de personnes
qui étaient reconnues comme réfugié par
l'asile français deuxièmement le Premier
ministre a annoncé dans son discours de
politique générale un projet de loi
Mayotte qui sera donc présenté très
prochainement au Conseil des ministres
qui prévoit sur les questions
économiques sociales de transport
d'infrastructure un changement radical
pour en effet faire de maotte un
département ce qui pose des questions
aussi de cotisation et de prestation et
qui doivent être la même que sur tout
territoire national enfin il faut un
changement constitutionnel nous
règlerons pas les questions migratoire à
mayott s'il n'y a pas un changement
radical dans la Constitution qui
s'applique à Mayot sur le droit du sol
et le droit du sang le président de la
République on a ouvert l'ugure je
propose d' travailler ensemble avec le
Sénat madame
[Applaudissements]
Jacques Mayotte comme l'ensemble des
autreemère a besoin d'un projet
ambitieux car la situation est aussi le
résultat d'une gestion Paracou et à trop
court terme je suis persuadé que l'on P
plus cher à long terme et à tout point
de vue ce que l'on repousse d'année en
année à Mayotte le gouvernement doit
donc s'attaquer aux causes profondes au
premiers rang desquels
l'immigration
merci la paraule est à notre collègue
Brigitte de Vezin pour le groupe de
l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question est adressée
au ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères monsieur séjourné tout le
monde se souvient du vol mh17 abattu en
Ukraine en 2014 par un missile sol air
tiré par les forces prorusses du donbas
aucun survivant parmi les 283 passagers
depuis le 1er février 2024 Pékin met en
danger la sécurité aérienne dans le
détroit de Taïwan un vol Air France
passe par ce couloir aérien
l'administration de l'aviation civile
chinoise a décidé unilatéralement d'une
modification de ses itinéraires de vol
dans le couloir aérien
m503 qui viennent désormais frôler la
frontière aérienne officieuse entre
Taïwan et la Chine l'objc de Pékin est
clair harceler les défenses aériennes de
Taïwan et de se servir du passage
d'avion civil pour camoufler des
manœuvres militaires Taïwan condamne
cette décision et pointe les
conséquences néfastes en terme de
sécurité des passagers internationaux
dont nos ressortissant en provenance et
à destination de shangï la révocation de
l'accord aérien conclue en 2015 entre
les deux rives du détroit de Taïwan
constitue un coup de force et porte
atteinte au statutco malgré résolution
du Sénat voté en 2021 mai 2021 et les
différents appels de nombreux pays comme
la France la Chine empêche la démocratie
tawanaise de siéger à l'Organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale la
question que je vous pose monsieur j'y
associe monsieur le ministre mon
collègue Olivier cadit que va faire la
France pour amener la Chine à revenir à
l'accord aérien conclu avec Taïwan en
2015 et sécuriser ainsi nos
ressortissants je vous
remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'Europe et
les affaires étrangères monsieur
sjourné merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice permettez-moi
d'abord peut-être un un commentaire sur
l'actualité que que vous venez de
décrire nous sommes évidemment très
préoccupé par les tensions croissantes
dans le détroit de Taïwan et pour être
très clair sur notre position et la
remettre ici de manière transparente
avec vous toute modif ation unilatérale
du statut nous sommes opposés ainsi que
tout usage de la force et de la
coersition nous y somes opposé également
pour être très clair la position de la
France est très constante de ce point de
vue-là c'est un message que la France
porte d'ailleurs à haut niveau auprès
des des autorités chinoises en les
encourageant d'ailleurs à privilégier le
dialogue et éviter toute escalade en
France la France est attachée à la paix
à la la sécurité de la région cette
position d'ailleurs se traduit par le
passage régulier de notre marine
nationale dans les EAU internationale du
détroit nous marquons ainsi en faisant
passer la Marine nationale notre
attachement à la liberté de navigation
et de survol conformément d'ailleurs au
au droits international que nous
revendiquons dans cette zone s'agissant
de
l'Organisation de l'aviation civile
puisque c'était votre
question nous regardons de près avec AC
nos partenaires le développement lié à
taiïwan et nous veillons dans ce cadre à
ce que son absence ne compromett pas la
sécurité aérienne évidemment mais plus
largement madame la sénatrice vous le
savez nous avons également une position
constante sur de ce point de vue nous
soutenons également dans le respect de
la politique d'une seule Chine la
participation de Taiwan au travaux
d'organisation internationale mais il
faut que les statuts le permettent et
que ce soit d'intérêt collectif et donc
cas par cas les organisations donneront
un avis que la France suivra à partir du
moment où nous sommes dans le cadre du
droit international merci Madame DEA
oui rapidement monsieur le ministre je
voudrais personne n'est dupe he ici la
Chine irritée par les résultats de la
présidentielle à Taïwan cherche
désormais à instrumentaliser l'aviation
civile par des considérations politiques
militaire je répète la France doit
appeler à l'ouverture de négociation
pour sauvegarder le statut Coo dans le
détroit de Taiwan fondé sur la paix la
sécurité dans le respect mutuel et celui
des règles de droit je vous remercie
merci merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mdames et messieurs les ministres nous
en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
prochaines auront lieu le 14 février
2024 à 15h je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour la
proposition de loi visant à interdire
les dispos électronique de vapotage à
usage unique la séance est
suspendue